good morning
millennials welcome back to the morning
toast happy thursday we're not quite
there
but it's thursday we're somewhere not
there
but almost there but this thursday is
unlike any thursday and it's a very
special day because
our new merch just dropped this morning
shopmorningtoast.com
get your beautiful stunning and smart
collection
merch it is beautiful stunning and smart
it really really is jackie and i are
wearing everything from the collection
i'm wearing the crew neck and a size
extra large
it is a different material if you bought
the how you doing or the redheads it's a
much lighter
um crew neck and i love it i'm wearing
an excel jackie's wears it in a medium
yes and today i am wearing the long
sleeve
crewneck t-shirt and so that's even
lighter than the sweatshirt and i'm also
wearing the sweatpants in a size medium
but like i said yesterday i might size
down in the sweatpants because they are
less fitted than what we normally have
put out we usually do like a
fitted jogger and so i like those to be
a little baggier but these are i'm just
like extremely short and it was time for
a small for me
so if you've been dying to just relive
your bar mitzvah days here you are
here you are it's really like taking me
back to a wonderful time of life me too
and i love to see it also i think it's
the comfiest stuff we've ever
dropped like i want to wear this around
my house all the time but i don't want
to
stain the white you know and like yeah
bruno comes in and he's like
conified and jumping around like ruining
the white so i have to protect it it's
actually really funny like what memories
people associate with this particular
style of font
for me it's obviously like bar mitzvah
giveaways like you had a little spray
paint during the cocktail hour but for a
lot of people it's the state fair yes i
saw those comments so i just find it
interesting like what
people's point of reference is for this
font because for me it's bar mitzvahs
yes no it's it's so interesting
no and it's like we're all just
connected like through this font we are
this font is really
connected connects our generation like
from all over the country all over the
world
i totally agree and it can connect with
you at shopmorningtoast.com
very well done we also have mugs by the
way this mug if you got the redheads mug
you'll recognize the size it's like a
it's an oversized mug it's uh it's the
best size mug possible if you're into
mugs you know what i'm saying and if you
just want to like
cuddle up with your blanket and your big
mug if you're into mugs it's the mug for
you
we also have phone cases so beautiful
stunning and smart
comes in almost every phone size
imaginable android and iphone
and we also have stickers so make sure
to subscribe slap one of those bad boys
on your skateboard
or your computer like most normal people
i'm putting it on my skateboard actually
i had a skateboard um when i was in
college it was a penny board
and you couldn't put stickers on it
because the material like wouldn't stick
i think i'm doing like
whole marvin the martian yes no way i
love marvin the martian
i do marvin the martian um great
reference we love that
yeah thank you um we have a fabulous
show obviously but um
i left my house last night and i hit the
town and i have to say the town hit me
right back
good yeah i you needed that i got into a
fight
well i heard i didn't really get into a
fight i just kind of like let someone
fight with me
you let someone like make a snide
comment to you and then you didn't pick
up on it until too late
yeah and it was just like so i was in
the waiting okay i went to the bathroom
at this restaurant it's like lounge
that it's a very confusing bathroom and
if you've had a few drinks it's really
dark it's all a mirrored hallway like
you can walk into a wall it's like a
very confusing bathroom
and there was one girl waiting outside
like a bunch of the stalls and i was
like
are you waiting for the bathroom and she
was like yeah i'm like are you sure
they're all
full because it's a confusing bathroom
and she's like no i'm just waiting here
for fun
and i like took one second to be like is
she being like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and she was and before i like before i
even knew she was being a [ __ ] and like
had something to say like a whole minute
had passed so like it would have been
really lame of me to like
come back with a retort 60 seconds later
but i was just like disappointed in her
because
i really feel like after all we've been
through as a city like we should really
be
more supportive of one another and now
like we're re-emerging like we should be
celebrating
yeah you would think so but i don't know
where you've been because that's not the
that's not the end what happened to new
york strong like what happened to all
the [ __ ] no it's new york go [ __ ]
yourself
literally and i just want to say if you
are a tall blonde woman with
shoulder-length hair who was at zero
bond at approximately 11 o'clock last
night
please come see me like i would love to
talk to you about what in your life
hurt you that you felt the need to
attack a little short girl at the
bathroom i didn't even say
anything and i wasn't being rude like oh
are you dumb you didn't look in the
bathroom stop
i was just like you are sure like if
somebody said that to me i wouldn't be
offended like
who hurt this girl she's yeah come see
about me okay
okay anyone knows a tall blonde girl now
you've had 12 hours
i'm still so mad no no to ruminate on
the insult what's your comeback
okay let's play it through okay yeah are
you waiting in line for the bathroom
no i'm waiting here for fun no no she
says yes yes
oh are you sure they're all taken no i'm
waiting here for fun
oh my god what the [ __ ] is your problem
that's what i would have said because
that's the message here like it wasn't a
confrontational conversation until she
made it that she's obviously a deeply
hurt person
i almost wanted to hug her because she's
obviously been through a lot
yeah i mean we all have i was just so
taken aback by the abrasiveness like
i'm sorry so you called me last night
while i was sleeping because you had
something to tell me and then you said
you were gonna tell me on the show
yes okay please tell me so last night i
went to dinner with a bunch of my
friends who i haven't seen
and one of my me and ben's like really
good couple friends is jordan and nikki
so they are they're engaged and me and
ben are really really close to them
they're like the best couple
and jordan went to my high school hour
high school and like you and jordan when
you were in like freshman year like
dated
like high school dates yeah just like
for his history um
it was like junior year okay so he
we were talking about um your i brought
it up do you remember
when jackie did that poem and she's
saying hannah montana yeah i don't think
he was in the class with me
but it was robert but it was it was
worldwide news and we spoke about that
on a previous episode if you don't know
what we're talking about yeah
and i just was like commenting on like
how iconic it was and he's like no i
don't really remember but
i don't know if jackie knows this but
like i was so like in love with her when
we were that's a lie
and this is what he said that's a lie
he said i was like so in love with
jackie when you're in high school like i
wanted to do something nice for her
and i knew she was obsessed with hannah
montana do you know this story i
i don't know continue okay so he's like
i don't know if she ever knew this but i
literally wrote a letter to miley cyrus
um like asking for like a signed picture
or something like you know how back in
the day i used to write like people's po
boxes
and you might get like a signed
autographed headshot in return and he
was like you know i literally like wrote
this long letter to miley and like sent
it to her p.o box
and um because i just like wanted to do
something nice for jackie and she never
wrote me back and i literally like my
jaw hit the floor i was like oh my god
that's so sweet
that's so nice i did not know that i
know i'm like i don't think jackie knows
that
i don't i didn't know that like i wish i
knew that then because um
that's just like not how i remember
things going down between us
oh okay you know so maybe you guys
should talk it out
he's getting married so like you guys
should talk it out so funny
yeah but um you know him in his new
fiance i'm glad it didn't work out
because like now i have this great
couple friend
and they're like so great for each other
and so great for me i'm happy for you
it's very tough when you have couple
friends because you always end up liking
you know like the husband or the wife
more
um and they're a rare couple that like i
like them both equally like i would hang
out with them individually or together
that's great but i do have a hard time
making couple friends do you
um no but i also don't have that many
and i feel like i don't have any couple
friends that i wasn't friends with when
they were
single right so yeah so you
automatically like this is like
my friend's partner right right but so
like when you make friends
as like a couple it's like different
yeah yeah i could see that and it's
actually
really fun because then like your friend
dates someone like you don't like
yeah it's like uh gotta see this guy
again yeah
interesting yes i just thought you would
enjoy that little piece of history i do
it now i need to like
like that's just not my memory of
the at that time it's incongruous with
my memory well
and actually a little fun fact i do
believe jordan's mom is like a big
toaster so maybe she'll hear this
oh my god maybe she'll hear us and she
could shed some more light on what
actually went down
as the adult in the situation yes
um so yeah that was my evening got into
a fight and learned more about jackie
which is
honestly not a bad evening for a
wednesday and you'd love to get into a
fight like let's be honest yes but i
lost like because she caught me so off
guard yeah i would have loved to come
back with some [ __ ]
retort here's the thing next time you'll
be prepared yeah no no i'm just going to
be on guard everywhere i go yeah and my
walls
and then and then you'll say to someone
no i'm waiting here for fun yes
somebody hurts it's cyclical and you
hurt people
you have to break the cycle i will but i
just will
you know how you break the cycle you let
it go ah
it's the hardest thing i can't you just
sounded like a nine-year-old jewish
grandmother
it's the hardest thing but somebody's
got to do it
i will but i just need some time i mean
this was literally 12 hours ago okay
we'll give you time
but then we let it go yeah i think
that's fair maybe we should have a
balloon
yeah or like we'll stage the room yeah
i'm letting it go it was just like
shocking you know the shock hasn't worn
off
yeah no that that could be shocking and
like traumatizing too
you know i'm over it i'm over it maybe
we should just dive in so i can get my
mind off of things
yes let us dive in we've allowed to talk
about real housewives of new jersey
recap
and we have some really great stories
today i'm really excited to just chat
about
some non-celeb related items she
actually decided to change it up a
little bit today i did because like i
don't know about you guys but sometimes
i get really [ __ ] sick of talking
about celebrities well like certain
celebrities i just get like fatigued
from talking about yeah
so we're switching it up in the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode to nobody's surprise
is brought to you by bruce
what a fabulous experience it's been
having my bruce for the last like six
months i feel like it is now
yeah coincidentally i brushed so hard
this morning like i was waiting
no no no like i was just going in with
my brush i was like bruce get in there
get back there and bruce
was up to the task and you know to be
honest if i'm gonna admit something
embarrassing before the bruce
i didn't always brush at night which is
like really disgusting
but now i've been like six months strong
because it's actually like a fun thing i
look forward to
um i'm six months strong of night time
100 of the time like
as much as i brush in the morning i
brush at night you know and if the brush
is good for nothing else it's really
good for that so if you don't know what
a brush is it is the most fabulous
electric toothbrush on the market it is
so effective
it is so fabulous and it doesn't cost
over 200
like most of the other electric
toothbrushes out there do which is kind
of crazy
the brush itself has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact
travel case so not only does it like
work really well everything about the
brush is very aesthetically pleasing
because you have to leave it on your
counter you don't want like some big
bulky machine it's very elegant it's
magnetic
it comes in these fabulous colors we
both have it in this like soft blush
pink
and if you travel the battery life lasts
so long you don't need to bring the
charger
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
they ship you new replacement heads
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head
which can lead to bad breath you're just
supposed to change it up but it's hard
to remember like when did i get the last
one
so they'll keep you on track with the
subscription program the electric
toothbrush has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design and it comes in trend
driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter get 15 off your bruce toothbrush
kit and refill plan
when you use the promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
love it okay first story
big news of the day kanye west is
reportedly worth more than
six billion dollars thanks to his yeezy
sneaker business making kanye west
the richest black man in us history wow
according to new reports by people and
bloomberg his estimated network
people people you know i respect people
me too not for my finance news though i
prefer you know bloomberg
well bloomberg corroborated oh okay okay
wow that's weird
yeah uh his net worth is estimated at
6.6 billion dollars in large part due
to his yeezy sneaker business which
bloomberg places between 3.2 billion
dollars and 4.7 billion dollars
after reviewing private documents
bloomberg also reports that west's
upcoming gap collab could be worth as
much as 970 million dollars
with additional income coming from his
music catalog cash
stocks and business investments
including
kim's skim's underwear brand apparently
he's an investor in that
wow good to know this is like a this is
a huge huge
for any celebrity to hit the billion
market we always celebrate over here and
the six billion and especially a
celebrity who a few years ago was
tweeting about how he used
it and a celebrity who now is making
history as what is it the world's
richest
the richest black man in us history
that's crazy and you know
i just always would have assumed that
jay-z was richer than him
because jay-z like from the beginning
has been very business savvy like
not even with his music but then with
roc nation and title and like all these
different ventures the nets they always
said he owned the nets
and so i would have thought jay-z was
richer than kanye but he's not
no that's crazy that is crazy i've
actually really been trying to get a
pair of yeezys recently
i have a pair you do and i've never worn
them oh you have the ones that they sent
you
yeah can i have them i don't know i like
they haven't taken them out of the box
because i feel like it's really like a
token of like one of our biggest
successes like kanye west reaching out
to us
yeah so here's my thoughts i don't know
if there are new toasters here who don't
remember that but just
google the morning toast closed on
sunday yeah and also there is a
conspiracy theory floating around that
like they actually didn't reach out and
that like we
thought like that we lost the former
toasters yeah yeah
which is like so crazy i have the email
yeah no you don't i don't have anything
to hide
that's like people also saying um like i
bought my own book and bought my way
onto the new york times bestseller which
by the way like
i did not do but whatever i still made
it
you didn't ask but like i swear on all
that is totally like i did not buy my
own book
no and that they did send us the sheet
music no actually i did buy like three
copies of my own book on amazon maybe
new york times knows that i did that
oh i bought i pre-ordered your book and
then i bought it on my kindle
yeah so i got two so i bought i shipped
i bulk bought
yes but um no we have the sheet like i
have the email you know all these
what is the craziest thing you've read
about us like people who
the thing is like we for a while have
like such
you know devoted fans and when they
decided that they didn't like us anymore
like the devotion they once had to
loving us
turned into like thinking about us 24 7.
like how can we destroy their business
how can we ruin their lives
and honestly the creativity was
momentous like it was
unbelievable the things people were
coming up with i think my personal
favorite thing that i've ever heard or
like
read someone say about us is like our
business is completely illegitimate we
have
all our money in offshore accounts and
we have investors in the morning toast
who like we're corrupting out of their
money
no and that we evade taxes by having
like a shell corporation like
in i mean it's not something i wouldn't
do but it's something i don't
currently do no and it was just stated
as fact yeah what we do
and by the way the girl who said i read
in a facebook group she was like uh
she works in compliance like she used
her work um her work
like like resources resources to like
investigate us and so like everyone
believed her she like had a fancy like
software
computer company and i was like oh my
girl like you
need to be fired like using company time
to investigate some podcasters like girl
um i think my favorite conspiracy was
that when we were canceled that it was
actually
my doing because i wanted to get out of
doing the show
and just like going with my little oh
you don't remember that no
no that was a big one you know i could
see that for you
no this is fun no i honestly like
it makes me feel really famous like when
people come up with like these crazy ass
things yeah i love that for us anyways
back to kanye and my quest
oh right to get have on my computer
there's a new um there's a
new collection dropping tomorrow for him
and i'm going to try and get
because i want to get them direct from
the yeezy site otherwise you have to
like play marco markups
yeah but stockx has a lot like if you
ever get desperate enough i've been on
stockx like investing here and
with cheesies like chunky ones so it's
tough because i
really want like the classic easy boosts
oh like with the rubber on the sides
yeah that are like like i really wanted
fake ones
i did well no i had the pink one so he
never made pink ones so it was like i
wasn't trying to pretend to anyone like
that
where'd you get those like pink ones
right um
so i want those because i think i'll
actually wear those the most but like
i also kind of want like the newer
cooler ones yeah but
i don't know so then i want like two
pairs and and i thought on stockx like
that's so expensive
yeah i kind of want the like croc slides
like that look like the
marvin the martian ones yeah those are
pretty cool so
now we know why you see his billions
dollar business
that's crazy like honestly i just when
when someone told me when i read that
headline for the first time last night
i'm like that is
definitely not true but now it's like
when you think about it it's 100 true
yeah but it's just confusing because for
so long he was like known as being the
guy in debt
yeah and now he's like not only not the
guy in dead he's the richest black man
in the world
or in america crazy we love to see it
we'd love to see and also whatever
phoenix
rising from the ashes what i was going
to say to you is you should wear your
easies because
i know but they're so persistent things
are meant to be worn and it's like
something that grinds my gear zach is a
big sneaker head and he has all of these
like really cool sneakers and he doesn't
wear them
and he winds up like wearing sneakers
from zara and i'm like
i'm like where are your sickening
[ __ ] sneakers like yeah but see like
you can't take them with you if they
crease that's true you can't take them
with you but
if he's if he's investing in them to one
day sell them like you have to
like he is but like he's been doing that
for so long and like there's no sales
yeah did he ever sell those dior ones no
when
oh that was dumb because like the moment
has passed yeah no the evaluation has
gone down in the stock market on
the stock market x [ __ ] i know so maybe
he should wear them
no now he definitely should yeah just
like that's my
that's my philosophy of the day i know
where are your nice things
i do but like because by the time you do
they're out of season
that's also incredibly true maybe i
should just wear them just wear them
just do it hashtag just do it okay
someone should
someone should use that as a slogan yeah
it's very powerful
maybe like a sportswear brad
okay are you ready for our next story
little hair news
what billy oh is teasing a sexy new
project
yes and driving fans wild with her new
hairstyle
yesterday she showcased a blonde
bombshell hairstyle that instantly won
over social media
the the hairstyle is pretty sickening
and considering we've known her for so
long as the black and green
girl this farrah fawcett style hair is
yeah a big change it's a sickening
hairstyle even for someone who didn't
have such a drastic change like yeah
and her instagram post reached a million
likes in six minutes which is a new
instagram record
wow and it's because obviously because
the change is so drastic but it also
just happens to be like the most
sickening hairstyle like the layers
the angles the like curl like it's
fabulous it is fabulous and she said i'm
gonna give you a new era i have
announcements to make i've got some [ __ ]
to
so yeah this is definitely signaling a
new era yeah i'm sure that means new
music it's very taylor swift of her yeah
i mean like she really did not have to
slap
that hard like just for a new era but
she did that for us
yeah but i think that given that
trucker's family are here truckers for
blind i like the haircut
it's truckers for blonde billy yeah they
said they like it um
given that her old hairstyle was so
iconic like she needed to come out of
the gate if she was going to change that
look
it needed to be on point yes and i'm
excited i was never like a huge fan of
the black and green hair it's just not
my personal style but i love that it was
like
so her but i'm very excited for like
i think it's what's gonna be like
glamorous bombshell billy as opposed to
edgy
you know emo billy yeah we'll see
get you a girl who could do both oh my
god theo smells so good today like
i've just been in the last 24 hours like
in a theo trance you know do you ever
have that like i i
just like can could not get enough bruce
trance i've been there a branch
are you ready for our next story sure a
little more like adidas news i guess
we're just like
adidas stands today it's actually adidas
i'm dead serious but not for me no not
for
not for me either but like people who
don't live in america like cannot
believe that we call it adidas like
we're 100 wrong it's adidas
and you know what it stands for all day
i dream about sports
no way adi no it stands for all day i
dream about
snacks yes yes and even little mix has a
song called a-d-i-d-a-s but it's all
tree
all day i dream about sex
i don't think they would be that over
okay what's the story
peloton and adidas are working together
on an exclusive apparel line which is
great news for me because some of the
apparel that i've gotten from peloton
has just been really [ __ ]
unflattering yeah i mean
i feel like apparel is probably not
their strong suit like the bikes are
strong and they should just like stick
with that no but like apparel could be
like can be an is for other brands like
a huge source of it
so good on them for outsourcing to
adidas right so many of my workout
clothes are from
school cycle because they had really
great workouts which was lululemon but
peloton and adidas announced thursday
that they're working together
to create a new line of athletic apparel
and lifestyle gear
in inclusive sizes and unisex styles oh
my god also speaking of
actually continue the collection was
dined with help from some of peloton's
top cycling instructors including
robin arzon ali love and cool and cody
rigsby my fave i've been sending you his
stuff
yes we're big fans and he's
so claudia's cup of tea speaking of
like inclusivity sizing news i read the
weirdest story that i just had to double
check
ann taylor loft plans on cutting their
plus-sized clothing by the fall like
just getting rid of it
i heard about that isn't that so weird
yeah
did i put out a statement or something
so somebody tweeted like hey loft is it
true you're discontinuing your
plus line they responded unfortunately
due to ongoing business challenges we've
had to make some difficult decisions
which does impact our plus collections
come fall our size offering will be
double zero to 18 aka extra extra small
to extra extra large
we sincerely apologize for any
disappointment um that's just like kind
of lame like why is that the first thing
to go you know when
like business is bad yeah i think like
as far as i know loft has kind of been
like um
very consistent in their plus size and
like really reliable like people have
always just like
and i can't imagine that it's actually
good for business to cut your applause
like
the average women woman in america is a
size 16. so like what are you doing
damn well you can get peloton adidas
apparel
yeah that's cool the merchandise will
include shorts hoodies tees crew necks
sports bras jogger pants retails
anywhere between 30.
the joggers she by sheree september
spring summer okay just because if
they're not i don't want
them i don't want it beginning on march
25th they'll be for sale on both
companies websites so if
you're cool interested i think that is
pretty cool i feel like i'm going to
start
buying some more like if it's good stuff
like why not be wearing peloton merch
it's
you know that's cool that's my source of
that's my primary source of exercise i
mean there is pellet toaster merch so it
should only be fair that there's actual
peloton merch
the pellet toasters shout out to you
guys are just such a great
community i agree very empowering be so
empowering very uplifting
okay ready for our next story um
[Music]
um ready come and
find me that used to be our [ __ ] jam
yeah who sings that song
cheryl crow no shania twain no i think
it's just like
sherry yeah sherry i knew that's what it
said
sheryl crow would never no what's your
favorite cheryl crow song
um on the count of three right no i'm
not ready
i'm not ready i need to look at her
catalog
the first kind no that's my least
favorite one what that's my least
favorite one i'll give you my favorite
one okay
has anyone ever seen cheryl crow and
jewel in the same room
no because they're literally the same
person okay here are the good ones
if it makes you happy
it can't be that bad
[Applause]
i'm gonna soak up the sun
i'm
[Music]
that's a great [ __ ] song okay and
then
all i wanna do is have some
fun don't know what nope and then
correct me if i'm wrong but does she
sing photograph with nickelback
she has a song about a photograph what
no
oh my god jackie photograph is a
nickelback like solo
endeavor through and through she has a
song about a picture with kid rock
same thing no so numb picture photograph
same thing kid rock nickelback same
thing photograph that's like
comparing a song to the national anthem
like you just can't be done i know but i
meant picture and if you heard the song
you would know it and i think no i know
the song
i think for those who are listening
there they see how i got from
ayden oh obviously i see it but i just
can't believe like you would ever like
not like fully understand the scope
of no i understand the scope of
photograph and i thought maybe like they
brought her in for a remix or something
but i also didn't think it like i was
thinking it through okay
i was thinking it through it was my
final answer okay
okay it was my final answer okay okay
next up a little makeup news little
interesting
makeup in the q news people are buying
more
above the mask makeup during the
pandemic the ulta ceo says
above the mask makeup like eyeliner
mascara and brow products did well
during the pandemic
other categories that farewell included
skincare clean beauty hair care and
fragrance
the ceo of ulta told cnbc that's
actually so interesting and on point now
that i think about it i
and i realized this the other day i
haven't bought a new lipstick
in well over a year yeah that's true i
actually feel like
makeup more so than any other industry
like wasn't as impacted by covid
just because i think people like were
desperate to feel like themselves at
home and like kept their makeup routine
for like
for the work day yeah i know i think
that a lot of people like
definitely scale back on makeup but so
much about like buying makeup isn't
about what you actually wear every day
it's like
fun palettes and yeah it's so it's
because a lot of people just like
collect makeup and don't even
use it yeah i'm done doing that me too
it's so wasteful and it just sits there
and expires
no and like i have all these palettes
and
i don't need them and i hold onto them
because i'm like one day like when we're
doing our halloween jonas brothers like
i'm going to need it
yeah no i also used to hold on to like
all of the packaging that my kylie
cosmetics came in because i just thought
it was so cute
goodbye yeah that's silly holding onto
the lip kit
um peppermint no no the box said like
when you buy a lip kit it comes in like
a kylie box
like the unicarton yeah that's crazy and
i have to start getting rid of those
things
yeah no i just like hate having like an
outpouring of makeup it's just like so
wasteful and so unnecessary
yeah so above the eye makeup and i also
feel like
about the mask brands like specifically
makeup brands like really could scale
back
in their packaging when it comes to like
pr like it's so wasteful like all the
confetti it's like terrible for the
environment like these
i literally i'm not gonna call it the
brand the bit when i got back from my
trip there was the
biggest box i swear on my life it was
the size of one of these couch cushions
guess what was inside two
cartons of ice cream because it had like
this big freezer
and this dry ice and i'm like this is so
[ __ ] wasteful like
for to i couldn't oh and they packaged
it so poorly the carton of ice cream was
open and the whole thing was melted on
like it was i had to throw the whole
thing away
it's just so wasteful that's also
because you were away
the carton was the no the carton was
open oh
it spilled out oh i thought the dry ice
melted but until you got home
just so wasteful like i feel like a lot
of brands like really need to scale the
[ __ ] back like you can send
and also like okay you have a new
foundation coming out like you don't
need to send the person all 40 shades
they probably only need three to five
like to figure out which one's theirs
right or you could ask them and right
like it's like what does
a person of one skin tone need like ten
other like it's just so stupid yeah
i hear that are you ready for our fifth
and final story
fifth and final a little tech
competition news okay
youtube's tick tock competitor hits the
u.s
what is it called shorts on thursday the
company said it's expanding the beta
program for its short form video
offering called shorts
to the us now and over the next several
weeks previously it tested the product
only in india
globally users have been able to view
shorts but not create them
youtube says its feature allows social
media creators to shoot
short catchy videos using nothing but
their mobile phones
sounds familiar yeah it offers a way to
string multiple clips together add music
and use a timer and countdown to record
videos literally
watch what tick tock is all features
currently available on tick tock
i mean i literally like just hit a
hundred thousand followers on tick tock
like please can we stop with this
rat race like i'm i'm a 26 year old
woman like i cannot keep up with all
these apps like yeah
reels it's like already so stupid but
i'm just like using it as i see fit
and it's just exhausting like to keep up
as a millennial like relax
yeah exhausted i really do reels has
been around for a while now and i really
don't think that it has posed any sort
of
threat to tick-tock and also i read
somewhere that the instagram algorithm
was going to be like
not prioritizing videos that have a
tick-tock watermark
or that what [ __ ] or that are like
not great quality which means you like
they took time and
re-uploaded it so they're really going
hard that's
crazy to me like you're gonna steal tick
tocks idea
and people okay we're playing the game
like we're uploading our tick tocks
that's what we did with instagram
stories we were saving our in our
snapchat stories
and uploading them to instagram stories
until most of us just eventually left
snapchat
right because instagram stories at the
end of the day were better products so
why don't you
create a better product why don't you
like innovate
something that makes reals more
compelling than tick tock
oh my god like that's so [ __ ] lame of
them and this shorts thing like
girl you are too late shorts go home
you're drunk
like we've settled this debate instagram
tried
if instagram can't copy you really
youtube
like good luck like in instagram is the
best at copying people
and they weren't successful so yeah
they're not going to be shorts but do
you think that youtube creators that
there will be some sort of ins
or it's like if you have a lot of
subscribers on youtube maybe somehow
that translates over to shorts
i don't know like you can spend a lot of
money on talent and
and content a la trailer which is tick
tock's biggest competitor
they literally pay for all those sway
boys they live in a house that has
triller everywhere like they spend
insane amounts of money on creators
to be on their platform like jlo's on it
and still like
nobody [ __ ] cares no but i'm not even
talking about spending money but like if
your
shorts profile is connected to your
youtube page where you are a creator
with millions of subscribers
wouldn't you want to utilize shorts
because you're already like the biggest
like influencer but most of those
enormous tick tocker
enormous youtubers are on tick tock and
have more followers on tick tock than
they even have on youtube
so like yeah like
it's too late like can everyone just
leave it alone like the ecosystem the
way it is now is good like we're happy
like we're fine we're all just like
living like leave us alone
yeah it's not like the streaming wars
like more
more streaming services like benefit us
more apps i don't feel like i'm
benefiting
because we're the ones who are creating
the content so you're just like
spreading the creator thinner and
thinner
right and i just think that like the way
it is now like tick tock one like
everyone needs to stop coming for its
neck like
it won yeah i mean anything can happen
though
yeah because i would have said snapchat
one yeah of course there were a few
years of of snapchat yeah but i just
feel like
the way that instagram annihilated
snapchat over the course of like a month
was so crazy to me well i'll tell you
what it was there were things about the
user experience on snapchat that were
kind of infuriating
one line of text yeah and snapchat like
wouldn't listen
and and then we went to instagram
stories and like every time someone had
a thought about like oh it'd be better
if the next day
it would be better if we could add a
swipe up link like they just kept adding
things
like the next day these changes would be
implemented before you even thought that
like you needed them and it just became
a better user experience a hundred
percent and they have not
successfully done that with reels um and
they haven't successfully done that
actually with anything since
and i find that making reels using like
their
platform is much harder than making it
of course so
you guys should sort that out yeah
honestly like
they could really use some beta you know
user some feedback
the moral of the story is go go home
shorts
um now it's time for our real housewives
of new jersey recap which is brought to
you
by today's sponsor imperfect foods
imperfections we all have them
so why do we hold our groceries to a
different standard get your groceries
from imperfect foods
to help create a kinder less wasteful
food system that embraces food of every
shape size
and physical appearance because every
year billions of pounds of food go to
waste
often because it doesn't live up to the
strict cosmetic standards of grocery
stores
don't you wish there was a way to
prevent all that waste and if you ever
want to skip the parking lots
crowds and lines and get right to the
good part of grocery shopping
imperfect foods can help get ready to
enjoy grocery shopping again
imperfect foods is on a mission to
reimagine grocery delivery for a kinder
less wasteful world
they deliver sustainable affordable
groceries including produce
protein eggs and dairy pantry staples
straight to your door
plus they're always adding fun and tasty
new discoveries for you to try every
week
all you have to do is sign up and create
your flexible personalized grocery plan
and then shop online each week and get
affordable and sustainable groceries
delivered directly to your door
with imperfect foods grocery shopping
fits seamlessly into your life and every
week is a tasty adventure
sign up with imperfect foods today to
save time save money
save food from growing to waste so
grocery delivery just in and of itself
is such a premium experience as opposed
to going to the grocery store like
finding a parking spot meeting a karen
like all the stuff
doing anything from home is just so
premium and that's literally what we
were just saying like so many of these
industries are so wasteful
especially food like the amount of
especially grocery stores the amount of
food they throw out it's just like so
silly
so imperfect foods is just trying to
change that and i have loved being a
part of it and i think you guys would
love it too
imperfect foods is offering our
listeners 20 off plus
free shipping on your first order when
you go to imperfectfoods.com
and make sure to use the promo code
toast try in perfect foods now for a
limited time to get 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order that's imperfectfoods.com
code toast to sign up for 20 off plus
free shipping
imperfectfoods.com promo code toast
love it okay so the real house of new
jersey last night was actually like
maybe one of my favorite episodes in
recent memory like nothing crazy
happened it was just
hysterical i feel like the women were in
rare form the men were in rare form and
that party looked really fun
it did it looked like a really good
party the pool is really stunning and i
love that we saw last year that like she
was thinking about a pool and now here
we have full circle
pool why is she selling the house if she
just put a pool in
i don't know but i feel like i've seen
that like she bought a new house with
her new man yeah
it has like 11 rooms because she has
five kids he has five kids like they
needed all these rooms
oh wow i guess it's like won the
memories i think it's like such an
expensive big house yeah she is going
off to college like it never
and i think like that house is so
symbolic of all of the
treachery treachery that they went
through as a family like i think that
for
them to move forward like the house had
to go yeah i just don't understand why
you would put a pool in maybe just to
increase like market value
like i guess houses in new jersey like
need a pool all the women have pools i'm
sure that it did increase market
that house has always been like a
haunted empty lot like it's a house with
no furniture and it's like uh
a yard with no grass like it's really
bizarre i can't imagine anyone would
have bought it like
if bravo should have bought it like the
museum of natural history
should have bought it just to preserve
the the sanctity of it
yes um but there was a few things to
unpack like i actually thought jackie
was gonna end up coming
and while i do respect her for being
like hell no like
theresa didn't even bite her melissa
invited her jack is not desperate like
jackie doesn't know that yeah because
they did a
scene they did a flashback to the scene
and
it was like jackie said she didn't even
tell me you told me oh really i think
i'm not sure
whatever i didn't think that she knew
while i respect jackie for like not
accepting a half-assed invitation like
get over it like get over it get over
the thing i still think what theresa did
was so wrong after watching the last
three episodes i have some i just got
over it
i have some additional thoughts like one
i thought that
the second party for evan like was it a
fine idea whatever
but like the way that she literally like
the party became incumbent on everyone
telling evan that they didn't believe it
like it was really weird
it was really cringey and joe joe worker
the next night was like how awkward was
last night no it was so awkward and like
she had to make another toast and it was
like
at a rest like it was just she throws
the worst parties you know the first
party for evan was in a parking lot
and i know we're in covid but like come
on and the second one was literally in a
packed restaurant like can we get some
privacy
yeah so i was just like this is just not
how i think
i would be handling all of this like on
the one hand like drawing even more
attention to it at her toes cheers to
the girls evan's [ __ ] at the gym like
girl but no no but like that was funny
but like
but it's not funny because joe benigno
says he also heard the rumor so now i'm
like okay
there's a lot there's a lot to talk
about and i don't remember cause i
watched them all yesterday i don't know
what was last night and what was in lake
george
so i thought it was it's just like
overkill the amount that she's talking
about it but i did think it
it did help evan to be around everyone
and be able to be light about it i'm
sure that week in the house where it's
like
just the whole world think like you know
so i think it was good but
just there was just they were trying she
was trying so hard like
yes girl like so now joe benigno says
that he has heard the rumors
i love joe benigno like literally
he is my father-in-law i cannot like see
him and not see bruce
and when margaret sat down with her
ghost writer and just like started
crying like i literally i love margaret
so much and like i just
i love them as a couple and they're they
really are like i think maybe in
housewife's history like the most
healthy normal couple like i love them
so much
sorry continue love them so much so when
joe benigno says that he's heard this
rumor in his house from like the girls
that margaret has over
and by the way he said it like not to
stir [ __ ] like it was literally an
offhand remark it's like he literally
thought
there forgot that there were cameras
there and that this is a reality show
and that's going to come bite you in the
ass and i feel bad for martin and your
wife
because obviously that means that
margaret has heard this rumor right and
that changes things because it's not
just like theresa heard one thing
but it also still teresa's in the wrong
because let's see so this is just an
[ __ ] here's the thing let's
let's go under the premise that this is
that it's true because this whole time i
thought it was
categorically false and i thought like
theresa liked straight up made it up
just to get back at jackie never thought
that she made it but i thought it was
like she got a rogue
instagram dm i'm sure she gets a million
about all the women she was like this
one
i shall take yeah and it's like well if
you want to go
on all unfounded rumors then let's talk
about them all but really let's talk
about none of that yeah
so let's say it is true she heard it
from a legitimate source and it's a true
the way that she went about it at evan's
birthday party
literally telling everyone who would
listen is wrong
saying it loudly so that his actual
friends who have nothing to do with the
show still heard it was
is still so evil no she's she's nasty
like she's a [ __ ] right because if she
genuinely cared and was like
wanting to you know be a woman who
supports women like she would have taken
jackie to lunch and told her
right or like told melissa to tell her
like yeah no the way that jennifer told
melissa about
the yeah but teresa's not like that like
she's
right but like how much he's never gonna
look out for someone how many times are
we is the
moral of the story just teresa's not
like that no it's unacceptable no it it
it's an un level playing field
yeah but now that it's like coming to
light that like it's very possible that
this could be true
it's like so annoying like i can't even
i don't even want to watch a reunion
because like theresa will feel justified
in her
actions but like still it's
unjustifiable
the way she did it right 100
so yeah and then also i will say just
given
like the teresa i feel like jackie could
have played it so differently
and really minimized it but she didn't
she might like just being like
like i feel like everyone at this point
just kind of ignores teresa and like
doesn't tell her them what she they
doesn't tell her what they actually
think or feel because they know that
like she's not receptive to
logic feedback so if jackie had just
been like oh theresa just wants to get
back at me and then like we moved on
i know now it's like center every single
episode we're talking about like does
evan cheat
no and now it's like at first i was like
it's uncategorically
categorically untrue now i'm like i
don't know i really trust joe budding
now i do
and he has no reason to lie no no i
don't think joe benigno is lying i'm
sure someone came into margaret's house
and said it that still doesn't make it
true it just means like oh theresa
didn't just
it's not just one person saying it yeah
no i and now that we're talking about it
for so long
it leaves people's imaginations wide
open yeah maybe there is
so i think that obviously you know he
has a reputation to uphold but i think
ultimately if it was if jackie never for
one second believed it to be true she
could have just
like just like ignored teresa and just
made her look like petty and crazy
yeah um but about the party it actually
looked so fun like i just
maybe i'm just like craving a pool party
but it looked like when they were like
in the pool
playing um
like it was like dolores and her bikini
and like just great everyone looked
amazing like i literally felt like i was
watching like teenagers
like but in a good way and they all
looked like so fire like their bodies
and their outfits and like i
i'm very hard on new jersey they're some
of the worst stressed women they all
like really brought it out i mean
melissa gorga like
her body is just she actually looks like
a teenager like it's the craziest thing
ever but all of the women
really look amazing especially this
season yeah
and i just like can't relate to having
gotten better looking good
yeah totally um the highlight of the
episode for me was obviously jennifer
ayden like getting so blacked out drunk
and to be honest i kind of lived for it
like i don't know
of course like you shouldn't get that
drunk but like whatever like we've all
been in covid like
nobody knows how to drink anymore like
she was in a safe place like her husband
was there he just like took her home
and i loved that like no one was being
judgey like all the everyone was like
actually trying to help and they like
thought it was funny
and i kind of loved that like obviously
i don't condone like getting so drunk
you can't stand but like
i don't know like you have a bunch of
kids they drive her [ __ ] nuts and
they don't [ __ ] help her like when
she put that whole meal together sat
down for two seconds and everyone was
already done eating and then like left
and didn't help with the dishes i'm like
i don't know how she does it and where
are her two nannies like where are they
i actually like really fell for her so
if she wants to go like get absolutely
hammered just so
just so she can sleep and her kids will
leave her alone like girlfriend
i empower you yeah i i saw nothing wrong
with it i thought it was funny i just
personally was like it made me never
want to drink again because i'm like
that feeling
of being like dizzy in someone's house
like and then you have that car ride
home and we know she lives a little bit
i think she likes them and and teresa
lives in um
like franklin lakes well yeah and so
that's a long drive
to be like so queasy unwell i never want
to have them
have the convertible open so you get
some fresh air i never want another sip
of alcohol in my life after watching
that i know but like the flashback
to bill aiden in jersey shore last
summer and um
them carrying him out of the car like
them carrying jennifer to the car like
get you a couple who could do both
100 i thought it was a really great
party
and jackie again just like with like
george is only punishing her she's
missing out
she is like and i understand that evan
might not want to be around the group
anymore fine
yeah but like when you sign on to the
show like it's not gonna be all good
like yeah there's gonna be
things like this yeah and you need to be
able to be like i know who we are
i know who you are i love you we have to
be able to without the outside noise and
yes it might affect his
business in some way but you can't go on
a reality show if you have a business
that's so
like sensitive and like right the
reality show makes [ __ ] out of everyone
but also this reality show brings
businesses of course
the scale tips both ways and you have to
be able to take the bad with the good so
i am by no means team teresa like in any
way i'm just like not as like
i'm not standing by jackie like she was
just like starting to bother me it's
like first of all you're missing out on
all this fun all these episodes and just
like get over it like
now that it's like not now that it's
like three episodes later it's like not
that big of a deal like
there's a rumor about ever literally
everyone's husband on reality show like
right
just get over it like you'll get back at
theresa another time she's not playing
the game right no not at all
as a housewife so even though i don't
agree with theresa i'm still like
ethically on jackie's side i don't
like the way that she's handling it
anymore yeah and at the end of the day
i actually would not be surprised if
jackie this is her last season like
she's so upset by this like
she's not letting go right but that's
where she's played herself because then
you go
out on my husband's a cheater and that's
what we remember you for and you give
theresa exactly what she wants because
she's one of you off the show from the
moment right and so when the more trips
you don't go on the more parties you
don't go to theresa is getting her way
and
yeah she's just like she's not seeing
the big picture no not at all she's and
that's surprising because i've always
thought she was really smart yeah but
she's not acting smart
no and she is like and they come for her
for being too emotional
and it's like i don't have the issue
with like the emotions like that they do
and i don't mind if she cries or
whatever but you have to be able
to like compartmentalize like this is a
job yeah like
you got to get back to the office yeah
like put your big girl panties on roll
up your sleeves and get back to work and
and you know what
get back at theresa yeah that's how you
can plan
that's how it works yeah also melissa's
short house is so
nice like so nice i actually feel like
definitely in new jersey but melissa's
house like even in
jersey is my favorite it's literally so
gorgeous and their new basement and like
go through the wine room and then you're
in the poker room and by the way they
just sold it which is so crazy to me
um but their short house is so nice and
when when was like this is literally
like my heaven happy place like
the pool and then the bay like it's so
nice so nice the outdoors
joey gorga like does home so we
obviously like made both of these homes
i would let him build me a house 100 the
outdoor bar yeah it was like sickening
the last piece of storyline is this new
housewife who's theresa's realtor
who said that was she a new housewife
yeah that's what i had that's what i
read
she's not a housewife yet but i read
before the season that theresa's realtor
is like the new cast member
i don't like it this is her way their
way of introducing her i think
yeah i think oh no her and her husband
are both like equally so [ __ ]
annoying like i'm thirsty like
i actually wanted to die watching joe
gorga talk to him because like it's
clear like i i believe joe gordon like i
don't think he's shady i think like
what he said in the wrong way like
riding my coattails is basically like
you didn't get paid for this event or
whatever deal we had because like being
a part of this event like will
bring you exposure it'll give you
instagram followers like we had an
agreement
like you would get paid like you're
whatever but we're not splitting this is
my event right the
the idea that they would be 50 50 when
it's like growing with gorga
it's not growing with gorga and jonathan
steinbreger
so and like he did registration and sold
tickets like that's not 50 50.
no like and and hosted a q a also
was like yeah you sent 10 guys who did
registration and you sent me a bill and
i paid it
right that's how it works so he just
like got ahead of himself he's like oh
my wife is going to be on housewives let
me like
let me you know get 50 50 on this deal
like he just got ahead of himself
and he made himself look really really
bad and his wife and when when his wife
was like to melissa like let's stay out
of this like
you [ __ ] started it by telling
jennifer aiden who you don't even know
yeah
i really don't like the new girl that
was really
a weird way to start but i'm glad that
they were able to like you know
reconcile chalk it up to a
misunderstanding yeah but at the end of
the day like
her and her husband were giving me like
such weird vibes because at the end of
the day like
all they wanted was the commission on
teresa's house so they were like okay so
like we're cool like
you'll still let my your sister like
sell my wife's house like like
chill the [ __ ] out like if you want
something you got to play the long game
like don't be so obvious about what you
want
so yeah we're cool right like i could
still like sell your house so i can make
your commission like
chill the [ __ ] out like take a step back
like nobody wants an
eager beaver real estate agent like be
cool
so like yeah i'm still like selling your
house right now and like a mission like
i have a buyer he's interested he wants
to come over tomorrow
chill the [ __ ] out girl like be cool yes
i agree be cool don't be all uncool but
i do think if this
woman comes in as a housewife like
that's a good adversary for melissa
yeah and um and i just wanna i wanna
know what the life of the top real
estate agent in new jersey is like like
i actually think that might be
interesting but her husband bothers me
so much like
so like you'll still let your sister
sell her house with my wife right
you'll still let my wife sell your
sister's house like be [ __ ] cool bro
yeah um but all in all it was actually
like a really good episode i
thoroughly enjoyed it and margaret
josephs is just like the queen of my
heart like every time i see her i just
love her so much
absolute queen and that's that on that
yeah
that is tonight is the premiere of the
final season of keeping up with the
kardashians on
e very emotional i don't even want to
watch it i don't even have to watch it
because
once i watch it like that it's over
whereas like with shit's creek i didn't
watch the f the final season for a year
and i had a year of like extended shit's
creek well here's the thing
i think there's a lot actually to unpack
that i'm hoping they address
in this season of course the kim and
kanye of it all
i would love to hear about like some of
the 818 backlash and like what that
meant to kendall
i think they were done filming by then
oh they were done filming by then
because the party with
the um all the cookies oh yeah
before yeah okay well so kim and kanye
that's really all i'm looking for
and i think scott sofia courtney
is i saw a preview that they do talk
about that
i mean because they're breaking up when
is the sit down with scott
about his grooming abilities only dating
18 year old girls i just think it's
something we should all talk about as
society
but them as a family as well i agree
i agree um i think i saw a headline that
there's a clip of kylie like crying
with kendall about kendall's acne like
growing up that it made her really sad
what i'll read you the headline
oh okay okay fine it was a part of their
drunk get ready with me which i've been
meaning to watch
on kylie's youtube channel that's
literally what i'm gonna treat myself
and there's also like the courtney one
there's actually a lot
once i get on a youtube like kick i
watch all of them but it takes me a
while to go to that
app okay i'm so glad like what you
thought isn't real because like
i've been trying to defend kendall and
sometimes she's indefensible so no i'll
just let me just read you what i
what i saw because i don't want to i
don't want to confuse people
you don't want to mince words it's not a
trending on people anymore
okay never mind i believe you i guess
not enough people click i believe you
there
it's clickbait it's [ __ ] clickbait
yeah yeah i just assumed it was about
the new season because like there's a
new season
so tomorrow we will recap the first
episode of the final new season of
keeping up with the kardashians on e so
make sure to watch that along with us
and if you didn't know that it's on
this is your reminder because like i
haven't really seen many commercials for
it except
the commercials that i do see with the
harry styles song like literally make me
so emotional
so it's too upsetting like that's what
i'm trying to say and i think like the
keeping up stands like
might feel this way too of just like i
don't once it starts like it has to end
yeah so i don't want to start it but
obviously i'm going to be watching it
tonight so we can recap it but like i
just want you to know that i'm in pain
do you think kendall like texted harry
like a link to the trailer like we used
your song
no because i don't think probably can
there's a chance kendall never even
actually they posted on their instagram
so she saw that commercial probably but
like
i think when it comes to like making a
commercial she literally is so
far removed i know but like the fact
that they use that song was like an
iconic
pop culture collaboration yeah there was
another job in history
there's another song that they there's
another commercial with another iconic
song
well they they love to use hallelujah oh
no it wasn't a kanye song it kind of
felt like like a rock song i'll have to
find it maybe it's a travis barker song
it might be um okay so stay tuned for
that tomorrow and that
is our show make sure to head over to
shopmorningtoast.com to check out our
brand new merch collection that just
dropped the beautiful stunning and smart
collection
phone cases mugs sweatshirts long sleeve
t-shirts sweatpants we got it all
and all previous merch if you're looking
to get a gift for someone some old merch
is up on the website
shopmorningtoast.com
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i heart
radio catbox all the places wherever you
listen podcasts
find us the morning chose to leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning
and smart we are hope you have an
amazing thursday we'll see you tomorrow
for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
bye bye